water resistance wireless charging
widgets on home screens there's an
endless list of things that have been
added to iPhones after Android phones
have had them for years like Apple's
notoriously late to adding things to the
iPhone I like to sit back and let other
companies beta test things and then when
they do jump in they like to plug it
into their ecosystem and do it the apple
way but sometimes that backfires so
Android phones have had always-on
displays for about a decade now and they
just added it to the newest iPhone 14
pro and it looks like this it keeps the
time and your wallpaper which is you
know the apple way but I and many others
after testing this have said look even
though it's one Hertz it does still feel
like your phone is not actually asleep
it's too bright like it's too on Android
phones make it super minimal for a
reason it saves battery life and it only
lights up the pixels with the
information that you need so in the
newest iOS 16.2 beta guess what Apple
listened and they added toggles to keep
the OAS on display but actually turn off
the wallpaper so you can save your
battery and still see your time and
notifications you know the way Android
phones have done it for years now